[Music]
outliers we all know them we all hate
them how can these data points just be
out of distribution not in the training
data things that we haven't seen before
things that we don't even expect well
they suck so today we're going to look
at what you can do about it specifically
we're going to look at the paper
learning what you don't know by virtual
outlier synthesis this paper presents a
technique to generate what it calls
virtual outliers which are synthetic
data points that are out of distribution
the core idea is that rather than trying
to come up with data space out of
distribution samples this paper comes up
with latent space out of distribution
samples which is much easier and much
more useful they're then designing a
loss that pushes down the energy of the
model wherever the outliers are and
pushes up the energy wherever the data
is this paper is really interesting
because it presented very successful
results on a multitude of benchmarks so
definitely this technique looks like it
works however when i read the paper i
was quite critical i had a lot of
criticisms i had a lot of open questions
and that's why i've invited the authors
for an interview to the channel so this
video right here is a comprehensive
paper review i'll explain in detail what
is in the paper what the method does
what its contributions are what its
experimental results look like what is
good about it and what i think is bad
about it then in the next video release
tomorrow i'll interview the authors of
the paper the authors will have seen my
review and therefore are able to respond
to any criticism and any questions that
i had so be sure to check out the
interview part as well because it was
really really cool to get all my
questions answered as always let me know
how i can improve these videos by
leaving a comment leave a like if you do
like and i'll see you around bye bye
do you have audio of someone talking do
you want that transcribed boy do i have
the product for you assembly ai builds
accurate speeched text apis which means
that developers can use these apis to
automatically transcribe and understand
audio and video data in just a few lines
of code and this works in the
traditional way where you upload audio
and you get back the transcription but
they can also do this real time so you
get a websocket to their neural network
powered backend and in real time it
gives you back text for your speech
that's insane but this is not all they
have a ton of features on top of that
for example they can do summarization
they can do topic detection they can do
bad word detection content moderation in
your audio and i have to say this is
really
good in fact i have uploaded this video
right here to their apis and the text
you see on screen is the raw output of
that model so judge yourself how good it
is we'll actually try some swiss german
words on it it is an english model but
we'll just give it a shot
half a hass
oh well isn't that great so give them a
try they even have a basic free tier
their documentation is super extensive
they give you walkthroughs and examples
of all the parameters that you can send
they have a great blog where they
describe different feature sets and
different ways of applying their
technology and yeah it's a really cool
thing now i've only scratched the
surface right here they do much more
they have features upon features on this
but it's best you check them out
yourself so thank you very much to
assembly ai for sponsoring this video is
really great please check them out a
link is in the description and i wish
you a lot of fun
[Music]
hello there today we'll look at vos
learning what you don't know by virtual
outlier synthesis by shifang do chow
ning wang mu tai and ishan li this paper
presents a model that can do out of
distribution detection in object
detection networks but not only in
object detection they show it on object
detection but it is a general framework
for detecting out of distribution data
at inference time if this really works
this could mean a lot for especially for
safety critical applications networks
that are deployed as a classifier or a
detector somewhere and they would be
able to recognize accurately when they
are presented with something they didn't
learn at training time like some out of
distribution class in this particular
case on the left here you see an image
which is an object detection network at
inference time it has correctly
recognized the car on the right hand
side however it thinks that the moose
here is a pedestrian it doesn't even
classify all of the moose but it
recognizes there is an object and the
class is pedestrian probably because it
hasn't hasn't seen uh moose's miss
what's the plural of moose in any case
it hasn't seen
a moose or multiple miss at training
time
and therefore it cannot classify it and
very often these networks make very very
high confidence predictions
for classes that they haven't seen
this paper tackles this and proposes
this technique called virtual outlier
synthesis to which we'll get to in a
second as i said it's a general
framework they demonstrated on object
detection which is a particularly hard
task but this could also be applied to
image classification they do make the
point that if you have an image like
this and you haven't seen the moose
class during training
most of the image will still be in
distribution like this will not be a
particularly out of distribution image
except for that small part with the
moose
however if you do object detection then
the object itself here is out of
distribution and maybe that makes
actually their tasks as researchers a
bit more easy because they are less
often in these ambiguous cases where
like half the data point is out of
distribution
in any case uh they mention here they
that the networks that we currently have
they often struggle to handle the
unknowns
and they assign high posterior
probability for out of distribution test
inputs now why might that be
if you train a typical classifier the
classifier will just attempt to separate
classes from each other you see this
here in the middle this is a projection
of the last layer of a neural network
right before the classifier layer so
right before the softmax so the last the
classification layer all it can do is it
can lay linear decision boundaries
essentially um
through the through the distribution of
of data points
so
the
what the model does is it sees three
classes right here so this is class one
this is class two this is class three
and what it needs to do is linearly
separate them so it says well okay i'm
gonna this is not an ideal color for
this uh
i'm going to
just put my decision boundaries like
this and now i've essentially separated
the classes because all that is
important to a classification loss is
that you know points in class 3 are away
from points in class one and away from
points in class two so that also means
that the more
away from classes one and two i go the
better like the more likely it is to be
class three because all i've ever seen
at training is
is samples from class three and my
entire objective was just to to
make it
to push it away or distinguish it
discriminated from class 1 and class 2.
so obviously if i go more into the
direction of class 3 the network will
become
will output a more and more confident
number about this being class 3. even
though as you can see the data is all in
this region right here and out there
there is no data yet the network is
still very very confident red here means
quite confident an ideal situation would
be if the network was very confident
where the training data is right here
however again we have the decision
boundaries like this however if you go
further out it will say something like
wait a minute even though this is not
class one for sure and not class 2 for
sure
it's most likely class 3 but still i
haven't seen any training data around
that area so i'm also going to be to
just output low a low probability or a
low confidence score i'm going to say
it's class 3 but i'm going to assign it
a low confidence because i haven't seen
actual training data in that vicinity
now this
all
seems intuitive and makes sense and so
on
mostly that is because low
dimensionality and high dimensionality
data is very different and can deceive
if you
look at it in this in a kind of a very
simple projection like this you as a
human you see this data and you go like
of course that makes total sense however
this it becomes very different if you
look at high dimensional data
note that there is a reason why our
classifiers do the thing on the left
because the thing on the right
essentially amounts to like a
probabilistic model of the data
distribution right the thing on the
right it has an idea where all the data
is right the thing on the left it just
needs to separate data from each other
three lines are enough for that the
thing on the right actually needs to
model the data in the latent space which
can become pretty complicated in high
high dimensions and it needs some very
very uh distinct assumptions to make it
tractable so the right thing is
essentially a generative model of the
data like a distributional model of the
data
which needs a lot more resources and
power and could
could
pull away
resources from the classification task
to be solved so what does this model do
um first of all they have some notation
right here uh which i
found to be
well let's just first look at the
diagram right here so this is the whole
model architecture they have an input
over here so there's input input x right
i'm going to use the green highlighter i
guess for this stuff um there's input x
you can see this is the this is the
input image
in general in general
first you have this
proposal generator and that proposal
generator will generate bounding boxes
so some of these detection networks they
have two stages
first proposal generation and then a
sort of a post-processing stage where
they assign labels to the proposals
so the proposal generator would simply
ask where are objects you know any sort
of object
the object ness property it sort of
generalizes between objects so it makes
sense to train the object detector to
just predict where are bounding boxes in
this case it will predict well there's
one here there's an object and there's
an object here and then it will pass on
those two to the
classifier to determine what's in the
bounding boxes and you can already see
the object detector has done a good job
it detected that this thing right here
is an object however
uh the classifier it what can it do
other it has to assign a label there is
no option for it to say no actually this
isn't an object
and previous methods have tried this
they've just added like an extra class
for
outlier it usually doesn't work too well
because the reason is pretty simple
in order to do that here on the left
you'd have to introduce like another
line and say okay so i'm going to
introduce another line i'm running out
of colors here introduce another line
you know like right here so this would
now be outlier
sorry outlier space well
that doesn't cover that doesn't cover
this region or this region or the region
back here right so having a single class
for outliers um is is sort of
useless because there are just so many
places where outliers could be uh and
not just like a single a single slice of
the space so you'd have to have many uh
you'd actually have to have like
a lot and ultimately that amounts to
exactly the situation on the right where
you know ultimately you're going to
train a classifier that is a threshold
between
low and high density areas and that's
exactly a generative model of of the
data
all right first stage is the bounding
box proposal this thing right here then
you pass on the bounding box to multiple
things first of all there is a loss
that's simply concerned with did you
detect the objects correctly so during
training the
proposal generator would simply be
trained with that loss right here now
everything here is back propagated
obviously but
that would be the main loss to localize
the bounding boxes
the second
the second stage here would be the
assignment of a label this would be the
so-called classification head
so that would take the latent
representation
that is generated including the bounding
box right so we're going to feed this
through a neural network and that will
give us a latent representation this h
thing mean that they call that the
latent representation right before the
classification layer and the
classification layer would assign a
label to it
and that would be the normal way of
doing things and now we augment that by
a bit
just to say they formulate this here as
saying we have a data set the data set
here contains
x is data b is bounding box and y is
labels so b and y would be the
the labels right that those would be the
things to predict
and then they say they split it up into
two
two things so first of all the p of the
bounding box and then the one of the
label and i don't think that's correct i
think that's a typo right here i think
this should be
the probability of the bounding box
given x not not the label and this
should probably be the probability of
the label given
x as well as the predicted bounding box
let's let's call this b-hat right here
the predicted bounding box so b-hat
would be sampled from this
but i this is this is minor
because the rest of the paper
essentially treats it as as i think i
write it down
in any case what they do in
addition to that is they also have this
classifier right here
the classifier that takes into
a
a
sample and the bounding box and it tries
to predict this number g and g is one
if the object is in distribution and g
should be zero if it's out of
distribution so this is a binary
classifier that classifies any sample
into in or out of distribution
independent of what the classifier head
says what class it is so that would
amount to
the situation on the right where if
you're anywhere in this region right
here the classifier would still say well
that's clearly class 3 because that's
the region of class 3 but your other
classifier would say yes but the
the outlier probability is very high the
in in layer probability is very low for
that region
so you can do outlier detection at
inference time
now how do we do this
we do this by generating these virtual
outliers during training virtual
outliers are essentially
outlier data points that you synthesize
now
you what you could do and they mentioned
that what you could do is you could
train like again
you can
simply train a generative model of the
data and then use that to sample out of
distribution data however they mentioned
that synthesizing images in the high
dimensional pixel space can be difficult
to optimize
instead our key idea is to synthesize
virtual outliers in the feature space
so the feature space is if you have your
you have your image right let's just
talk about classifier you feed it
through a bunch of neural networks and
then here
is the last layer and all you do at the
end is you have a classification head
that classifies it into multiple
classes and this right here is just
described by a matrix w this is just a
linear
layer that goes from the amount of
features i guess d or something like
this to the amount of classes c
that's the dimensionality so in this
space at the end you would do
in this space right here that's the
space we've seen in in these diagrams up
there
here is where we would sample the
virtual outliers so what we would do is
we would
look at our training data where does our
training data fall we say aha okay there
is class ones two and three as we had it
then we build
a gaussian mixture model of the training
data essentially we'd assume that each
class has is described well by a high
dimensional by a multivariate gaussian
they all share the covariance matrix by
the way and then
we would say well okay given that that
is the case which ends up at the
situation on in the right
we would sample
we'd sample data points from outside of
those gaussians so that have a
sufficiently low probability so these
would be these virtual outliers we would
just sample them anywhere where we where
our gaussian mixture model says that
there is no data
but still
we sample according to the gaussians so
we're not going to be like way out here
in undefined space
just because this is in our support set
we're still going to sample from these
gaussians but we're going to sample
until we get a sample that has a very
low likelihood so
we're deliberately going to sample
outliers from these gaussians
and that those are going to serve
as samples for our outlier classifier so
then the outlier classifier what it
needs to do is it needs to find a
decision boundary between
these virtual outliers and
and the data you can see
draw this right here so
there's going to be a decision boundary
now
you can see this decision boundary gets
quite a bit more complicated than the
decision boundary of the
of between the classes especially you
know given that we do it in the last
layer
so
we'll go on in in the paper a little bit
um what we just said
is gonna come up in a second here so
they say we assume the feature
representation of object instances forms
a class conditional multivariate
gaussian distribution
and they
state this right here so every class has
a mean all the classes share a
covariance matrix and they do calculate
they don't learn these things they do
just calculate them from the training
data in an online fashion so this is in
the penultimate layer of the neural
network as i just said
yeah they compute empirical class mean
and covariance of training samples and
they do this in an online sorry about
that in an online estimation fashion
which means that as they train the
network they collect the training data
and then in an online fashion they
compute these metrics to always be up to
date
they do say here we assume the feature
representation is this gaussian let's
say c figure 3 and figure 3 is a umap
projection
of
umap visualization of feature embeddings
of the pascal voc data set
and i'm not sure what they mean by look
at figure three
this is a umap this is like a
a projection a non-linear projection
into low dimensional space if i'm i'm
i'm not exactly
remembering what umap does but for sure
this is a projection like this doesn't
convince me that the data is gaussian it
convinces me that the data is kind of
in one place ish
right um
like or like
it convinces me that all the blue points
are closer or most of the blue points
are closer to each other than they are
close to for example the green points
here like that that is what
is convincing to me from this graphic it
is not at all convincing that in the
original high dimensional space where
they come from they are somehow a
cluster or
a gaussian even or even that all of
these classes would have the same
covariance matrix
even if they were gaussians so that that
is it is a wild assumption
um but you know it seems to work so the
results of the paper are that they
are very very good at this outlier
detection they reduce false positive
rates by a lot so you know it seems to
work i'm just saying this does not
convince me
um
or maybe i don't understand umap uh
maybe there is something so here is
where they say they sample the virtual
outliers from in this feature
representation space
using the multivariate distributions so
they would simply sample the virtual
outliers uh from the gaussians but the
gauss
but then evaluate them and only take
them if they
their likelihood is smaller than some
epsilon
they say it's sufficiently small so that
the samples sample outliers are near the
class boundary
um
yeah these outliers would then be
converted to
to the output so this would be the
output the classifier head
by the classifier matrix
now
that is
that is how they sample the outliers
and
you know all all good so far i have a
few concerns right here for example
uh what you're going to teach the model
is you know successfully um
if in the last layer before the
classifier
there is a data point and that data
point does not is not where
the training data is then
if this model works it will in fact it
will recognize it as an outlier right
what will not happen
and and this seems yeah okay what will
not be the case if if that
that moose right here for some reason
right an earlier layer already confuses
it with something right an earlier layer
thinks oh this you know it's four legs
it's probably like it looks like a dog
right then the moose will come will come
to lie
really inside of the dog class because
it would have the features of a dog
which the lower layers would have
confused it so you'd have to have done
this technique in one of the lower
layers and there you could see that that
this is an outlier but the lower the
layers you go you know the less your
data
even less your data looks like a
gaussian i mean ultimately you'd have to
do it in the input layer right and there
it becomes clear that this is just like
a a distribution of the data that you're
trying to approximate and in the input
layer certainly this is not a gaussian
at all
so i think
this only works for specific outliers if
there is an outlier that
as i say has like the same features
as some
in distribution data
resulting that in the last layer they
are
in like inside of this cluster then this
method will not be able to detect it um
yeah that is that is kind of my
one concern the other concern i've
already said is that this
separating these outliers is naturally a
harder task because uh yeah as well it
essentially amounts to a generative or a
distributional model of the data rather
than just a discriminative classifier
so how are they
incorporating this into training now
during training
we still we still don't know right we
have
so up here
right we have our
loss right here for the localization we
have a classification loss which um is
is fine is good uh so our classification
loss tells us if we have the class
correctly but we still need a third
thing which is this uncertainty loss uh
we are going to
estimate
the uncertainty which is going to be our
measure of how much
out of this how much the model thinks
that this is an out-of-distribution data
point or not
and
how are they doing it
they are using
the log partition function for that
so the log partition function is a
it's this thing right here
um
it's essentially
essentially what is at the bottom of the
soft max if you use a soft max for
classification so if the f here
is the logit of class k
so if this is the output of your
classifier and then you do a soft max in
the last layer across your logits
the softmax would look like this right
so you'd have the class y at the top and
then you'd have that log some x of the
uh of all the classes at the bottom so
the bottom right here is kind of like a
measure of how peaky your distribution
is right if if you're if you're if your
logits are
you know one is just standing out
heavily then that is kind of a measure
for uh low uncertainty like you're quite
sure about what you're you're doing and
if the all the logics are kind of the
same then
this um
they they are they're all more even so
this measure is a little bit of an
indicator of certainty right
so this was already this was already
shown to be an effective uncertainty
measurement for out of distribution
detection so what we're going to do is
we're going to use this
as a
uncertainty loss right here so what
we're going to do is we're going to
to train or not to train we're going to
have a
log logit based loss so we're going to
say we are going to use a sigmoid
and
what we want is we want
this measure right here we want the uh
we want this
right here which is one is the one is
the log it and one is one minus the
logit i
can't remember which one is which in any
case um we want this measure to be
high for in distribution data and low
for out of distribution data or the
other way around want the uncertainty to
be high for out of distribution data and
low for in distribution data
so if we get a data point we'll plug it
in to this free energy um
well the uh
by the way this the negative of the log
partition function is called the free
energy sorry i for got to mention that
that would make some connections to
other even other fields of science
so we're going to take our data point
and we're going to not plug it into the
classifier but just this bottom part of
the classifier right
to measure is the distribution that
we're getting very certain or very
uncertain
and then what we want is that if we have
a true data point
then we want the we want the
uncertainty to be very low
if we have a
fake data point we want the uncertainty
to be very high okay so by adding this
loss right here
by adding this loss
what this does is this trains our
classifier to be more certain if the
data point is real and less certain if
the data point is fake which ultimately
right
will result
in
decision boundaries like this or
certainty estimates like this on the
right here
so the
um certainty estimate on the left would
just be if we just train the classifier
objective the
thing will get more and more certain as
we go away from the classification
boundaries if we look at this certainty
measure
and now we explicitly train the model
to only be certain around the data and
to be again very uncertain around all
the virtual
all the virtual outliers so that's why
you see blue anywhere away from the data
we explicitly train the model to
to do that
so our
uncertainty classifier that we talked
about where was it this thing right here
our uncertainty classifier is not in
fact an additionally trained model uh it
is simply us plugging a data point into
this uncertainty measure and during
training we make sure that this measure
is
low
for fake data and high for clean data
now
this loss if i see this correctly it is
uncertainty loss initially it will only
it will directly affect this parameter
set right here since we only generate
the fake data in the last layer the only
parameters that are really affected
by this loss in that case is the
classification weights right here
however implicitly obviously by saying
that
the true data here must have a
high certainty or a low uncertainty
um
and by contrasting this with the fake
data in the last layer it may also be
that through back propagation the entire
network is shaped such that the latent
space will be more optimal for doing
this classification however right i i
cannot
conceive super well how this you know
how all the effects and and counter
effects and so on are gonna
work out uh but it would be interesting
to think a bit more clearly through that
um yeah so
what we're gonna end up with is a
probabilistic score for out of
distribution detection
our loss is going to be a mixture of
these classification and localization
losses and the uncertainty loss
got added with a given hyper parameter
so this is going to be our detector for
in distribution
we simply take
predicted or we take an inference sample
we take the predicted bounding box we'll
plug it into this uncertainty estimate
right here so this here is this free
energy we plug it into the sigmoid
formula here
and that will give us uh one if
the classifier is very certain and the
zero if it's very uncertain
that this is in distribution data we can
define a threshold and that's going to
be our out of distribution classifier so
that's it for the method
they go through a bunch of results now
i'll shorten the results by saying
they're just very good at everything
like it at the data sets they try
against the baseline baselines
they do ablations and particularly
noteworthy for example here is the false
positive rate where lower is better you
can see if they were just to add an
outlier class
this would hurt the performance quite a
bit like
more than
other modifications right here which i
found interesting to see
um
yeah they detect they compare against
other outlier detection methods and
uh they they do have i believe
some samples right here
needless to say yeah i have my concerns
but it does work pretty well so
and i'm just a person that looks at this
paper for the first time and hasn't
worked in this field at all and hasn't
tried anything so i'm going to give the
uh
the um
the right away to the authors right here
but let me know what you think
and i'll i'll see you next time
[Music]
you